these ants are working in tandem to form
a bridge even though there's no leader
giving orders they all seem to know what
to do
similarly thousands of starlings flying
unison creating complex formations in
the sky magnetic properties arrives from
the alignment of billions of electrons
intricate frost patterns crystallize on
window panes hurricanes form above
churning oceans and once clear highways
suddenly get jammed with traffic these
different systems all share something in
common some sort of macro property or
behavior arises spontaneously from many
interacting micro parts it's a classic
case of the whole being greater than the
sum of its parts the behavior of each of
those parts doesn't predict how they
behave collectively some of our greatest
unsolved mysteries like how life first
began and how our brains give rise to
consciousness could be explained by this
phenomenon known as emergence
[Music]
how does complexity emerge from a simple
starting point and how do we even study
that let's look at the formation of a
crystal lattice think of molecules in a
container at high temperatures they'll
bounce around independently in a fluid
or gaseous state poke them and nothing
happens to the system but lower the
temperature and they form a solid they
crystallize arranging themselves in a
regular lattice a balancing act between
opposing forces maintains the distance
between molecules
now poke them they'll try to restore the
balance the key is the forces acting on
the molecules don't change the drop in
temperature and it a new condition to
the system the same rules created a
different effect and that's how the
properties of the crystal lattice like
its rigidity its elasticity and its
long-range order
emerge an abrupt change in the behavior
of a physical system is something we
typically think of as a phase transition
in fact that's how scientists stop and
think about emergence in more complex
systems let's return to the bridge
building ants like the molecules in the
lattice the ants as individuals obey the
same behavioral rules no matter what
they're doing they
trying to build structures but when the
ground drops away in front of the swarm
old rules about how close to state of
their neighbors leads to the emergence
of large-scale coordinated behavior
without that information about their
neighbors the bridge would break apart
just like how higher temperatures cause
molecules to break from a solid lattice
into a liquid state emergence means that
we can find hierarchies of new laws and
structures that arise out of complexity
at different scales scientists are
seeking to apply the framework of
emergence to other areas of research
like how individual cells follow cues to
move a transform when organs are
developing or how groups of neurons fire
together to help you make decisions some
researchers are even hoping to engineer
such systems of their own to build
robotic systems made up of small dumb
parts that end up swarming together to
perform useful tasks perhaps this work
can help us understand even deeper
questions about the emergent nature of
intelligence consciousness and life
itself
[Music]
you